[Applause]
so I think they've been friends for what
a little bit over a year you know I
think we click because we're total
opposites
we are very opposite I'm most anxious
person that I know of and I don't
consider you to be right I wear overalls
to shoes I think we have a pretty
similar sense of humor what is this
where's the other it's in the back okay
sure it's called sigh off we are going
to the premier 57 Spa we're gonna go to
some saunas we're gonna go to some steam
rooms and we're gonna get naked I
haven't been to a spa I've never been to
a spa so this is huge for me that's how
I react to nudity I'm allergic to it
yeah I just want to be more comfortable
with my body and I'd like to think that
by being naked
suddenly I'm just gonna be really
comfortable I'm excited though I'm
excited to go just follow through
challenge our friendship a best
friendship are you ready to go to the
spa I'm ready I'm scared so we got there
at 8:00 a.m. we put on some very lovely
comfortable robes and slippers very
swanky oh and they gave us water free
water the moment someone gives me a non
tap water yep
I'm very impressed we went to sauna
Valley there are a number of different
saunas for anyone that likes anything
my favorite saw was the color therapy
room that was just like I'm just like
it's a never-ending photo shoot I really
like the Himalayan salt sauna Wow
Florida's warm Walia feels nice I also
really liked the igloo room which I do
not like I liked that I felt like I was
inside of a refrigerator and I always
wonder what it's like but if I like to
eat it so we went to the hydrotherapy
pool after some sangria just to loosen
me up depressed a bunch of buttons a
bunch of jets came out you're feeling
ready to get me
now in Revit why are you just not
changing you look like Dracula I you'll
pitch this I did I did this [ __ ] but I'm
suddenly remembering what I agreed to do
how can she be so chill what if there's
something wrong with my body
we went to the water lounge get into
these showers where you rinse off when
you were showering and then the book
going okay what are you coming up
becoming a town that was the moment I
was like I could leave
well I felt calm about it I think like
right before we did it I was like oh but
I also do think that I can only imagine
how you were feeling and if I felt like
a tinge of it you must have been during
that times a hundred
it definitely wasn't as scary as I
thought
I learned that all bodies essentially
all have the same parts well if you
didn't know that before I would be
concerned I felt a lot more comfortable
once we got in the hot tub mm-hmm you
were essentially excited for any parts
that helped you censor your body we're
naked I like it you should go be nice
today sir yeah let's go to and then we
dance we dance
I almost I've never been able to say
that it my mind I thought spas work for
like bachelorette parties and man you're
significant on there yeah turns out you
can go with your friends I would do it
again I would do it again I mean the
spot was really nice it was really
relaxing yeah we felt boozy but like in
a good way I got naked today I didn't
chicken out which is honestly something
I was worried about I just think
everyone is beautiful and I really
appreciate everyone from who they are
externally internally yeah and it was
just like access to each other in a way
that was more vulnerable and intimate
[Music]